you just found yourself the tales of mr.
collector a limited-edition story
collection from doctor one detainment oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
my name is Jeremy Adams and I'm 22 when
I'm being chased by a monster I don't
know what's going on I don't know how
this is possible or what I'm supposed to
do the thing won't stop I've been
running for oh god only 15 minutes feels
like longer
I'm exhausted it won't stop I didn't do
anything wrong I just saw this guy in
the subway it's night we were the only
people in the car he looked a bit odd
but grey and glassy eyed which was odd
because from his hands I guess he was
black or indeed or something we got off
the same stop and I guess I wasn't
looking where I was going because I
bumped into him and his head fell off I
mean that doesn't happen and then he got
up and chased after me that that can't
happened
how is it even following me anyhow it's
not like it has eyes
another doors locked no can someone have
left their door unlocked tonight please
I just need to get away from this thing
and there it is how did it get behind me
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] Trash Can I grab one and
swing it straight into the things chest
and it stumbles backwards and collapses
and I'm off running before I can get
back up thank you adrenalin who can this
le be a dead end that can't be I need to
escape it not fair
walls walls damn it too high too slick
and it's found me anything around no I
can't fight but I try to punch it and
it's strong and this doesn't make any
sense is that a blade is
much much better it hardly even here
with that old one by the end this one's
good young healthy should last me for
weeks
colorblind you can't have everything
and let's see reasonably bright - I just
hope I didn't get too far off track
getting this one mr. red I'm coming for
you and I can't wait to find out what
wonderful thoughts I can think with that
head of yours
[Music]
Oh
[Music]